so I have a question how many of you
have ever done something illegal from
what I can gather the perception that
people tend to have of me is one of a
slightly loony but generally wholesome
polite young mummys boy but everybody
has their dirty secrets even Charlie
it's so cool like and my secret or at
least one of them is that I used to
steal Mars bars I put it down to peer
pressure really but when I was little I
found myself in a group of friends that
were layabouts as it were and every day
after school we would go down to the
local shop shelf Mars bars down our
sleeves and then walk out like we
thought we were cool for some reason
stolen Mars bars never tasted quite as
good as Mars bar that I'd actually buy I
think the stolen Mars bars tasted too
much like guilts one time I was in the
shop and one of the Mars bars fell out
of my sleeve onto the floor the
shopkeeper was like what and I ran as
fast as I possibly could and never went
back in that shop again however I will
confess that stealing Mars bars is not
the only illegal thing that I've ever
done I don't consider myself a betting
man but I am willing to wager that if
you are watching this video which you
obviously are then you probably have at
some point downloaded something
illegally I feel pretty comfortable
talking about it to be honest because it
is something that a lot of people do or
at least probably have done at some
point in the past and I think it's made
out to be worse than it actually is I
mean if I had to pick which one was the
worst crime stealing Mars bars or
illegal file sharing I would probably
say that stealing Mars bars is the worst
crime my rationale for this is like if
you go into a shop and you steal a Mars
bar then the shop owner has one less
Mars bar but in the case of file-sharing
where you're making copies of the same
song or whatever it's essentially the
same as having magic Mars bars exactly
the same scenario you go into a shop you
take a Mars bar but in the spots where
your Mars bar would slay a brand new
Mars bar appears as if by magic the shop
owner has exactly the same number of
Mars bars as they did before and you
have a free Mars bar a magic Mars bar as
well now I want to make it clear that
I'm not trying to justify downloading
stuff illegally I'm just trying to say
that it isn't as bad as a lot of people
make it out to be from the shop owners
perspective the situation still
definitely isn't perfect even with magic
Mars bars I mean if you can get free
Mars bars then why the hell are you ever
gonna buy a Mars bar but from my
perspective getting that free Mars bar
is almost the same as getting a free
sample take this for example if you get
that free Mars bar and you've never had
a Mars bar before and you try this Mars
bar you know that's the best chocolate
bar I've ever eaten in mind
if you genuinely like the Mars bar then
the logical conclusion is that if you
want more Mars bars you can have to
start buying Mars bars so here's the
people that make Mars bars need money to
make those Mars bars and if you don't
pay the money then they're not gonna
make any more Mars bars new don't get
any more Mars bars buy even free ones I
just want to be clear that Mars bars
aren't sponsoring me to make this video
I could have said the whole thing
exactly the same of twixes it wouldn't
have mattered
they're not paying me so yeah the same
is true I think of people that farm
share if you say download a movie and
you really like that movie then you're
gonna want to support the person who's
made that movie so that they can make
more movies it's just logical
common-sense that's just my opinion I
mean as well as being of the generation
that download stuff illegally I am also
a musician I make some of my livelihood
from making and selling music so I am on
the receiving end of this as well for
example my first solo album called this
is me comes out today and there's no
doubt in my mind that people are gonna
want to listen to that album for free
and that they're gonna do whatever they
have to to listen to it for free and I'm
not going to fight against this alright
I'm going to embrace it and say that if
you want to listen to my album for free
then you can go to Charlie McDonnell
calm /music there's a flash player on
that it plays the whole album completely
for free and best of all it's completely
legal as well the album is also
available on iTunes and Amazon mp3 and
if you want to get a physical CD you can
get one from dftba.com I'll put all of
the links down in the description
underneath this video so if you want to
buy a copy and support me then you
completely can but if you don't want to
then as I always say you don't have to
you can do whatever you want what you
like by the way if you're interested
these are boxes of my CD and this is my
friend Alex showing off what the CD
actually looks like I would show you one
but I don't have a copy I'm really
excited about it and I've absolutely
loved hearing what people have thought
of it so far so um I hope you liked it
if you do get a copy and that's all
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool